the world consumes a lot of Steel and
that process releases lots of Planet
warming gases more than all of India
does every year
the process of making steel hasn't
changed all that much in thousands of
years basically it works by burning cobs
of coal with iron ore dug up from mines
is mainly iron atoms attached to oxygen
atoms the violent chemical reaction uses
carbon from coal to remove that unwanted
oxygen releasing iron metal
all the while making billions of tons of
carbon dioxide
tackling climate change requires getting
to zero emissions that means cutting out
emissions from the steel industry all
together
a new colorado-based startup called
Elektra claims to have found a solution
its process does not use any coal at all
instead it uses renewable electricity
from solar panels or wind turbines and
Powers the removal of oxygen from Iron
Ore using only electricity
and it can run that reaction at a
temperature cooler than the water needed
to make your coffee
thus the process can work whenever the
sun shines or the wind blows rather than
the 24 7 that steel plants have to run
today
but Electra only makes carbon free Iron
there's still an extra step involved
where very small amounts of other metals
and some carbon needs to be added to
iron to make the many different kinds of
Steel the world consumes
still Electro solution Cuts 90 of the
emissions in making steel
the startup is only two years old and it
has lots of work ahead of it
it needs to prove that its process can
work at scale producing billions of tons
of steel that the world consumes today
and it has competition in other startups
and major steel companies that want to
use green electricity or green hydrogen
to do the same job without carbon
emissions nonetheless elektra's
Innovative route is a massive step in
the right direction
this is zero for more follow us on your
favorite platforms